So, we agree that banking is about money.
But finance is also about money.
Does this mean that banking and finance are the same?
Not really.
Banks are financial institutions but so are insurance companies and investment companies.
Some financial institutions provide banking services, but they cannot be defined as a bank.
Why not?
Because they do not fulfill the legal definition of a bank.
In Britain, all financial institutions are controlled by the Financial Services Authority or FSA.
There is legislation covering the services provided by each institution.
A bank is a government-licensed institution.
It is established under a government charter.
A banking license gives the right to conduct banking services,...
...particularly services related to the storing or keeping...
...of deposits and the extending or offering of credit.